[Music]
that was really awesome just classic
cheese pizza like yeah really
straightforward fun pizza maybe but
weird Los Angeles mm-hmm where
California Pizza I kind of started
alright let's let's me let's get weird
let's get weird let's make some pizzas
don't let me get some toppings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Russ hey so I got something like la food
yeah I'm rich Brian and I'm Joey
last summer we became master chefs at
the 88 rising summer mansion and this
year we're teaming up with even more
chefs and special guests and asking a
few of our 80 a rising labelmates to
help us out
welcome to the feast mansion
welcome to the feast mansion welcome to
the feast mansion welcome to the feast
mansion so I got something like la food
okay right you're familiar all right we
have the double-double classic Roscoe's
chicken and waffles
Langer's biscotti really what we're
gonna do is like yeah I'll make pizza
with it you know I don't know what you
guys think I want to make a high-risk
high-reward pizza but I don't want to
just do something that's automatically
gonna fail can you do a chicken and
waffles pizza like do you think it makes
any sense to go that route now I think
all this is completely idiotic right but
what I want to tell you is keep as much
liquid away from the dough as possible
like do it in moderation I keep it fun
and then keep it fun yeah because I mean
it's fun to be like a total idiot
exactly so that's what we're doing all
right so we can all just make it yeah
thank you guys I'm gonna step back I'm
here to coach just holler at me I'm
right here wait you know okay okay
supervising I'm like the lifeguard
[Music]
that Shelly go Chili's gopher did you
see I'm gonna watch Sean for a sec
classic she gotta move right there
ah that right in here no no no Sean
just trust me trust me trust me trust me
oh I'm go kinda just make sure let's
tickle it on the edge yeah I will fun so
you have some fun out here it's what
we're here for
no I'm going for a chili dog pizza here
Chili's and dogs good move
so was inspiring you Sean the birds the
beach
the last bird that lived was in 1978 and
then now every bird that exists out
there or robots now they're all drones
mm-hmm that's why they're on the power
lines cuz they're charging up oh I'm
doing a moat ammo to a motor room emotes
Institute what is it wasn't moats wood
what do you know you tell me it's not
your servo motor oh yes it up I'm doing
a bit of moose or el obvious [ __ ] I
might [ __ ] with the coleslaw because I'm
Pro coleslaw a pizza
you like do you like coleslaw in general
yeah yeah I'm gonna trust me anymore I'm
just doing whatever I feel like would
taste good I'm not sure what style I'm
going for yet but this is how I usually
cook with the pesto boat Cousteau or
pizza right here oh you're gonna just
put that right in the middle let's eat
yeah I'm your super
[Music]
what is this white gelatinous stuff here
ohhhh yup ohhhh yup sorry game over
it's all great over time you need to
spend no o muddled but we're here today
where you're gonna have some fun right
yeah oh no you're right I [ __ ] this up
no I can solve it you don't have a JIT
it's a lasagne pizza now I pulled up
with Alfredo's they were all afraid of
me
it should be like a cigar or something I
tried but it didn't work
[Music]
are you how can you feel it over there
shot you ready to fire it up I am ready
to fire it up do you have any onions if
not that's okay butters not gonna write
them I did oh yeah little onion action
yeah that looks good Shawn I mean it's
artful your distribution of them insane
I like I like do you think the
presentation is important I mean with
your eyes first that's what they say I
think about this yeah yeah that's
alright I'm just gonna do a bit of
correction here with the sauce okay it's
movin we're gonna go in I mean excuse me
sir I'm just gonna pop this open I'm
changing up the game a little bit
putting some fried chicken on there this
just gonna smack change Jenga game I
think
did you pull that from the display Oh
chick Hayes has been out there for a
long time but it's cute jump nicely for
you right there
yeah I was going for more like kind of
least one non Chipotle vibe you feel me
because in their cubed up in Tripoli I
mean it there's not he's not like out of
them he's not out about it's not free
this coleslaw kind of looks right is a
perfect combination he's sweaty like the
obvious move was go for the pastrami
buddy mom he's it when you fight as good
as that I gave it the I gave the
pastrami the lowest rating to really I'm
doing a dumb ass right now LA's finest
all mixed up pizza pie Mel plus alfredo
sauce
[Music]
there is being cocoa in ours
yeah yep there's like a transformation
in the Steve Urkel becoming Stephane
every time we pop up from the earth take
a look at the what are you gonna call
that Shawn this is the the Shawn's
footlong special and this is the pizza
the fried chicken was [ __ ] crazy why
am I always snapping someone please tell
me I so Jodi's pizza's ready Shawn
speech though is also ready and my
pizzas in the oven now but I feel like
we need a judge or something you need
something that won't taste their food
and and I tell us which one's the best
one objective because I know there are
some abominations yeah I'm neither was a
pizza judge once and I promised myself I
would never do that
no one talks about fair Tyra but fair
yeah thumbs up fair okay I know somebody
in my okay Nicki yeah yeah she's here
[Music]
Nicki this is the big chili
it is a pizza version of Pink's chili
dogs so we have a chili base some
chopped up hot dogs cheese onions in the
pizza oven out the pizza oven and made
specially for you gotcha
hey Nikki this one is called the shower
curtain puller it's coleslaw some Swiss
cheese most realities and bits of fried
chicken with just a Motorola bass no no
that's not it marinara marinara sorry I
almost freaked out right all right this
one's called How I Met Your Mother has
some pastrami and there's some pepperoni
and then some cheese and some pesto in
the middle okay all right freakin all
right you guys um I'm scared and excited
at the same time I'm just gonna do this
laughs I did
mmm mm-hmm
is that a good Remus so fun fact my dad
used to work at Pink's oh he won so I
like that texturally it's very doggy
that was that's what I was going for
right so all right on to the next one
yeah pick a help you I'll be slice short
this is chicken yeah let's go Alfredo in
it - that's what I forgot to say oh come
on oh no oh come on
is that good when she laughs on the bite
I don't come on what you think the
alfredo is not like okay interesting
okay that doesn't go in the middle
that's the ass right in the middle I
don't know how to feel about that he
gets pastrami - that was a good bite ya
know the artists vision
yeah whole artist vision came together
right they're really nervous man all
right just stay away from the coleslaw
so
that's a it's a really close call you
guys okay what I say
[Music]
but I think did you like it did you like
it was delicious the cross looks great
too look at that
yes dog has a factor nostalgia and it's
also the way you pitched it so like I
expected it and my brains would be like
for this to be but doggy and girls like
exactly that so like hit they can't all
the executed I'm not good this is this
is also very it's eclectic
right right heavy I think that one's
just like your classic like okay if I
had like not an Asian grandma like you I
would feel like I would make something
like this to save my legs but yeah like
overall three very good pizzas but mine
was the best
yes there you go so Anthony we didn't
tell you this but they were gone for a
while and while you were going we made a
hot sauce together you guys know we
ain't we are one pretty pretty harmless
what is it what's in it
holy [ __ ] that's the pitch you know
Brian I have something to tell you too
what you guys are making these pizzas I
made my own la pizza are you serious
yeah it's called Sancho's backdoor
really and it's a yeah oh you got it
right there yeah it's go away it's an
outdoor pizza and what did that come
from that's great
pineapple puree on the bottom mozzarella
diced onion pickled jalapeno and a pet
store pork fish was a little cilantro on
top I really like the juxtaposition yeah
yeah so I was going forward um thank you
all right well I think that we need to
try this pizza with the dab I'm just
gonna go I'm gonna dab a wrench and
finish this pizza off this a lot I don't
know about finished it off all right
that's it should we do it
look we go for it all right
Sancho's back door meats dragging in the
clouds Cheers pineapple oh there's some
dairy
Oh oh-ha you know Shawn [ __ ] you man
they go so so we all made pizza today
and we all learn how to make it beats up
and then we're all dying and I think I'm
having a panic attack but I'm not sure
but I think overall it was a great
experience right Anthony I'm so glad you
guys invited me to your mansion I'm so
happy to make beats up I have good you
come here we gonna say bye to the camera
okay good bye bye
[ __ ] dude whose mansion greatest [ __ ]
Cookman show in the world
yeah he's no doubt no doubt
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking in with a very
exciting hot sauce update our first ever
collaborative sauce it's here
88 rising first we feast joining forces
to make dragon in the clouds
you saw me Joe G and rich Brian mixing
it up in the cauldron yuzu from Japan
etc I'm peppercorn from China and of
course you know your boy brought the
heat but don't worry we got some
professionals together to make sure this
stuff is FDA approved extremely limited
very quality and something why we're
super proud of if you want to get your
hands on dragon in the clouds visit 88
night market calm that's 88 night market
calm don't miss your chance the dragon
you can fly away
[Music]
you